7 mai 2012 vladimir poutine entre au
kremlin son troisième mandat de
président au pouvoir depuis près de
quinze ans il vient d'être réélu dès le
premier tour en prenant ma fonction de
président de la fédération de russie
je mesure toute ma responsabilité devant
la nation et rhodia les pères de la
nation pour certains chefs de clan pour
les autres car l'homme le plus puissant
de russie serait aussi milliardaire pour
moi il est l'homme le plus riche
d'europe
je pense qu'ils procèdent 40 milliards
de dollars plus cher cadeaux masters
[Musique]
c'est la rouge là bas la datcha de
putschiste ce genre de maison ça vaut
des centaines de milliers de dollars
et nous à la police on s'est toujours
demandé comment il avait trouvé l'argent
pour cela payer un beau diable
voici le fameux palais de poutine
vladimir poutine serait la clé de voûte
d'un système de corruption généralisée
comme crème leader pour succéder au fort
ou qui n'étaient assis au bout de la
table
il s'agissait de vols d'argent public
est bon début 10 milliards enfin ça
c'est fini à 12 milliards
km de route 7 en moyenne 149 millions
d'euros c'est inexplicable
il n'y a aucun prix comparable dans le
monde là les liens incestueux entre le
monde de l'argent et la politique pro
jamais été aussi puissant écoute il fait
taire tous ceux qui auront l'audace la
naïveté de le suggérer
enquête dans l'ombre d'un hasard qui
aimait l'argent
[Musique]
on
pour vladimir poutine
tout a commencé à saint pétersbourg la
deuxième ville de russie
c'est là qu'il est né en 1952 dans une
famille ouvrière dans les années 70 il
entame une carrière au kgb les services
secrets de l'urss
une élite qui va s'emparer des meilleurs
postes après la chute du rideau de fer
1991 le système soviétique implose
l'admirent poutine devient le bras droit
du maire de saint pétersbourg pour la
première fois il se retrouve mêlé au
monde des affaires
ambiance gros contrats et millions de
dollars pour découvrir ce qui s'est joué
à l'époque il faut s'enfoncer dans la
russie profonde à des centaines de
kilomètres de saint pétersbourg
des villages abandonnés et puis enfin ce
hameau absent des cartes
c'est ici que s'était réfugié une
ennemie intime de vladimir poutine
conseillère municipale de saint
pétersbourg marine à s'allier est morte
au printemps 2012
c'est sa soeur qui nous reçoit chez free
attend nicolas natalia font des risques
pour que le combat de sa soeur ne soit
pas oublié je salue on va aller d'une
voix la marina la photo a été prise
juste après son élection au conseil
municipal de saint pétersbourg elle
voulait changer la politique menée dans
le pays marina s'allier la femme qui a
failli faire tomber vladimir poutine dès
son entrée en politique je n'ai lu elle
soupçonne l'adjoint poutine de profité
de son poste pour s'enrichir à l'époque
l'urss vient de disparaître
le pouvoir est passé de gorbatchev et
eltsine
le pays est désorganisée saint
pétersbourg frôlé la pénurie alimentaire
la mission de l'adjoint poutine remplir
les épiceries
pour cela il va proposer à des
entreprises étrangères un troc à grande
échelle matières premières russes contre
nourriture venus de l'ouest
bois pétrole métaux on peut farine huile
et viande problème en déclenchant une
enquête municipal sur ce système marine
à s'allier découvre que parfois les
matières premières russes n'était pas
échangé mais vendus et l'argent empoché
par des responsables de la mairie du
dossier original d'accusation il ne
reste aujourd'hui qu'un seul exemplaire
tapé à la machine
voilà le rapport d' enquête municipales
de 1989
la ruse c'était que la plupart du temps
il n'y avait rien qui revenait en
échange des matières premières les
firmes locales russe
qui concluaient les accords disparaît
c'est très vite et l'argent aussi
disparaît c'est ma soeur marina corvée
que presque 900 millions de dollars
avaient disparu dans les transactions
pour les enquêteurs la fraude ne fait
pas de doute
question l'adjoint au maire poutine l'a
t-il seulement couverte ou carrément
organisée l'analyse des prix indiqué
dans le contrat témoigne du caractère
criminel des conditions de l'accord la
dîmière poutine a motivé son refus de
répondre à l' enquête par la nécessité
de protéger des secrets commerciaux
l'enquète de la conseillère municipale
et transmise à moscou poutine manque
alors de perdre son poste
new administration présidentielle avons
reçu des documents qui témoignent de la
possible nécessité d'une éviction de
vladimir poutine de son poste nous
demandons à l'administration de saint
pétersbourg de veiller à ne pas le
nommer à de nouvelles responsabilités
un des documents clés qui a plombé
l'adjoint poutine cette licence
d'exportation permettant le troc
matières premières contre nourriture
poutine l'a signé alors que cela
n'entrait pas dans ses compétences
vous voyez là la signature de poutine et
son adjoint poutine
la signature vladimir vladimirovitch
poutine
[Musique]
coutinho xiang mais poutine faisait ça
pour prendre de l'argent
je ne suis pas au courant pas devant une
caméra
les gens peuvent ils y a encore de la
peur on ne sait jamais ce à quoi on peut
s'attendre ce dossier qui pourrait lui
valoir des ennuis
natalia le conserve hors de chez elles
quelque part dans la forêt en 1992
comment vladimir poutine at il réagi à
cette enquête municipal l'accusant de
corruption
[Musique]
nous avons retrouvé deux élus présents
au conseil municipal du 23 mars
le jour où le rapport a été rendu public
en présence de l'adjoint poutine
[Musique]
poutine a dit que rien n'était prouvé
que tout était douteux au contraire il
avait très bien travaillé et que si des
lois avait été enfin si vous était allé
au delà des limites de leurs compétences
ce n'était pas avec des buts personnels
mais pour le bien de la ville
à l'époque les élus d'opposition n'en
croit pas un mot
ils transmettent le dossier à la justice
mais la surprise aucune enquête n'est
ouverte
la justice aurait pu ouvrir une enquête
sur ce schéma de son rugby
mais pour cela il aurait fallu qu'on la
laisse travailler et à mon avis
clairement on ne l'a pas laissé faire le
système faisait que la décision
d'enquêté ne pouvait venir que du
pouvoir donc en ce cas du maire ou de
poutine lui-même sur danny lee hye ja
qui lui désordre la sphère en tout cas
sera enterré jusqu'en 2007 année là
vladimir poutine un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle dans un
livre-entretien des journalistes lui
reparle du scandale de saint-pétersbourg
il y a bien eu une enquête dirigée par
marina s'allier sur votre travail à la
mairie
[Musique]
oui en fait il n'y a presque pas eu d'
enquête et il ne pouvait pas y en avoir
il n'y avait rien à chercher sur qui ou
quoi que ce soit d'un point de vue pénal
et l'attribution de licences
d'exportation nous n'avions pas le droit
d'en attribuer curieux des licences
d'exportation signé poutine figure bien
dans l' enquête municipal de marine à
s'allier
21 ans après cette affaire le dossier
est prescrit la justice russe ne pourra
plus y intéresser mais à l'époque
l'enquète de marine à s'allier avait
éveillé l'intérêt d'un autre franc
tireur un officier de police
[Musique]
voici ma carte de policier de l'époque
du comité d' enquête
c'est la preuve vous voyez pas que
j'étais bien lieutenant-colonel du
comité d' enquête
rattaché au ministère de l'intérieur
suite à la sphère de saint pétersbourg
le policier eekhof avait gardé un oeil
sur l'adjoint poutine en 1996 il
découvre qu'il a créé une société
immobilière avec des amis et qu'il s'est
offert une maison de campagne
voilà c'est la rouge avec l'antenne
satellite sur le toit une belle
propriété avec ses dépendances et un
accès direct au lac en 2000 alors
candidat à la présidentielle outin
reconnaissez dans sa déclaration de
patrimoine posséder cette grosse
propriété trop belle pour les maigres
revenus d'un simple adjoint au maire
dans la russie des années 90 en tant
qu'adjoint au maire
poutine gagner au mieux 400 dollars par
mois et à l'époque il y avait une
inflation terrible c'était très
compliqué de survivre avec cette somme
surtout avec une famille ce genre de
maison ça vaut des centaines de milliers
de dollars
des noues à la police on s'est toujours
demandé comment il avait trouvé l'argent
pour se la payer
en enquêtant le policier ses collègues
découvrent qu'en marge de son travail
d'adjoint au maire
poutine s'est discrètement lancer dans
les affaires on a découvert qu'il était
co créateur ou cogérante une quinzaine
d'une vingtaine d'entreprises cela
n'apparaissait pas publiquement
officiellement poutine n'avait pas
d'autres revenus que son salaire
d'adjoint au maire
après les poules 20 situe depuis
vladimir poutine aurait revendu sa
maison du lac
quant au lieutenant colonel lykov devenu
gênant il a été renvoyé de la police
[Musique]
alors qu'il n'est encore qu'un
politicien débutants vladimir poutine
paraît déjà intouchable
[Musique]
en 1996 le président boris eltsine
l'appel à moscou l'occasion pour poutine
de se rapprocher du pouvoir politique et
financier
moscou la richissime 80% du business du
pays se fait ici quand vladimir poutine
débarque dans la capitale boris eltsine
vient d'être réélu président en trois
ans il va faire du provincial de st
petersbourg un rouage essentiel du
kremlin août 1996
poutine est nommé adjoint aux affaires
présidentielles mars 1997 adjoint à la
direction de l'administration
présidentielle juillet 1998
poutine devient directeur du fsb l'ex
kgb à l'époque c'est un poste à environ
1000 dollars par mois
toujours pas de quoi faire fortune mais
vladimir poutine est désormais l'un des
hommes les plus puissants de russie en
cette même année 1998
le procureur général de russie iouri
secours a tough découvre qu'un chantier
de rénovation du kremlin a manifestement
donné lieu à des pots de vin le nom de
yale ciné cité le monde entier se
passionne pour la faire la famille elle
chine serait-elle corrompus la justice
suisse saisie trois contes
approvisionnant trois cartes de crédit
titulaire boris eltsine et ses deux
filles elena et tatiana ici à gauche de
l'image des comptes approvisionnés par
une entreprise mabetex
mabetex une société suisse de travaux
publics qui vient de remporter le
chantier de la rénovation du kremlin
pourquoi mabetex verser tel de l'argent
à eltsine et à ses filles à genève
nous rencontrons l'un des magistrats
suisses ayant enquêté sur la sphère nous
avons ouvert une procédure suisse pour
blanchiment d'argent et constater
qu'effectivement des sommes suspecte
avait été versée en rapport avec avec
ces travaux de rénovation et qui avez
vous découvert des contrats de pots de
vin quoi carrément des contrats de
corruption en occurrence on avait la
preuve et du crime d'origine et de du
passage de son produit et de ses valeurs
par la place financière de nous qu'on
avait tous les éléments nous pour
poursuivre pour poursuivre le
blanchiment d'argent
à moscou le président eltsine comprend
qu'il est menacé
le kremlin cherche une issue la solution
va s'appeler vladimir poutine à tout
mettre d'un incroyable coup politique
le 31 décembre 1999
yalcin s'adresse au pays pour échapper à
la justice
il va lâcher le pouvoir c'est fait
respectant la constitution en
démissionnant j'ai signé le décret
nommant président par intérim
elle admire vladimirovitch poutine pour
qui la
[Musique]
la guerre russe chers concitoyens
aujourd'hui j'ai ri de la responsabilité
de chef de l'état ce 31 décembre le jour
même poutine signe son premier décret
présidentiel
oukase en russe une immunité totale pour
eltsine et sa famille
les garanties apportées au président en
quittant ses fonctions et à sa famille
le président helsinn démissionnaire
bénéficie de l'immunité
il ne peut être retenue arrêtés fouillés
ou interrogé à moscou nous retrouvons le
procureur iouri secours a tough
c'est lui qui avait repéré des
magouilles au kremlin et alerté la
justice suisse avec lukasz de poutine en
faveur de eltsine
il comprend tout de suite que son
enquête et torpillé groupe des projets
de l'opération a réussi y évoquer un
président corrompu a choisi son
successeur et prie aime les grosses
boîtes hausse cette opération a été
préparée en détail est l'un de ces
détails étaient que les enquêtes sur
helsinn les soies stocks mais ça c'était
l'une des obligations de poutine envers
haïti
[Musique]
avec le recul l'ancien procureur a des
mots très durs
helsinn c'est moche et poutine
c'est un peu comme s'ils avaient formé
il ya une famille loudyi et ce terme de
famille on sait ce que ça veut dire le
toucher mais offrait dumas fils armes au
poignet t chimie et la mafia c'est la
famille faits étayés chez mia de fait
une fois poutine président la ferme à
bettex sera enterré comme prévu depuis
l'étrange ascension de vladimir poutine
s'est transformé en règne 15 ans de
pouvoir ininterrompu et sur toutes les
télés une omniprésence qui tourne au
culte de la personnalité
l'homme proche du peuple
le croyant
[Applaudissements]
le puissant parmi les puissants
le combattant
l'homme proche de la nature
écolo même guidon avec son ulm une
colonie de grues cendrées
le pianiste
[Musique]
mais derrière cette propagande
l'adjoint sulfureux de saint pétersbourg
at il refait du business une fois devenu
président à moscou
un ancien du kremlin va nous mettre sur
une nouvelle piste
cet homme aujourd'hui
andrei illarionov fréquente les réunions
de l'opposition sous la surveillance de
la police
mais entre 2000 et 2005
il faisait partie du premier cercle de
vladimir poutine il était même le sherpa
du président économistes intègre il
avait hésité avant d'accepter ce poste
exposé on s'est bien entendu est à sa
troisième demande j'ai fini par accepter
le poste 12 avril 2000 poutine a signé
ma nomination pour nous à chenini à 5
ans comme sherpa jusqu'à un gros
incident survenu en décembre 2005 le
kremlin prépare alors l'introduction en
bourse d'un géant russe du pétrole
rosneft une privatisation partielle qui
doit rapporter 12 milliards de dollars à
l'état actionnaire
mais lors d'une réunion andrei
illarionov découvre un tout autre
circuit financier
il n'a pas été prévu que le trésor
public en cas ces 12 milliards
ce sont des dirigeants de la compagnie
russe proche du kremlin qui doivent
prendre le contrôle du magot choqué le
sherpa dénonce l'opération devant le
président poutine et tout le premier
cercle
j'ai dit que c'était du vol podium
poutine était au bout de la table de
réunion
il s'est éloigné il a dit ce n'est pas
moi c'est dimitri medvedev qui a monté
l'opération
après ça medvedev a dit tout cela est
légal je me suis retrouvé le seul à
défendre l'argent qui devait revenir à
l'état ni le premier ministre ni le
ministre de l'économie ni le chef de
l'administration ni le président ne
m'ont soutenu pour moi c'était délicat
citons chef commet un acte délictueux et
que tu rêves
alors c'est que tu cautionnes cet acte
j'ai donc donné ma démission dans la
foulée
un départ fracassant et puis plus rien
sur les 12 milliards qui ont échappé à
l'état la justice ne bouge pas quant à
vladimir poutine
malgré une conférence de presse d'andré
illarionov pour dénoncer la manoeuvre
il ne prendra même pas la peine de
répondre mais ces 12 milliards détournés
sont ils un cas isolé
[Musique]
politologue stanislav belkovski travail
sur la corruption en russie
pour lui le vol d'argent public est
généralisée j'estime que 30% du budget
fédéral aujourd'hui et volé dans tous
les ministères les commissions et les
pots-de-vin commence à 30% de la valeur
des contrats et finissent à 70% ce type
d'économie est totalement basée sur la
corruption une corruption systémique
aucun contrat public petit ou grand n'y
échapperai exemple avec la première
autoroute payante de russie entre moscou
et saint pétersbourg
en 2009 le groupe français vinci
remporte l'appel d'offres sur des bases
apparemment surévalués par l'état russe
colère des riverains l'autoroute
traverse une zone protégée qui vient
d'être déclassé sur instruction de
poutine
ce n'est pas un progrès c'est un recul
allez venez sauver la forêt la dîmière
poutine bellay les protestations il ya
toujours des antagonismes entre le
développement et la protection de la
nature mais il faut construire cette
route
mais depuis plusieurs mois les opposants
sont violemment réprimées leurs figures
de proue un journaliste local
ce colosse me file beketov dès 2008
il affirme dans un article que le
déclassement de la forêt par vladimir
poutine at-il légal
quelques jours plus tard sa voiture est
incendiée devant chez lui
je savais que je paierais pour mon
article mais beketov persiste dans un
second article
il affirme que la préparation de l'appel
d'offres pour l'autoroute a été truqué
cette fois il est battu à mort et ne
survit que par miracle quand nous le
rencontrons en 2010 le colosse n'est
plus que l'ombre de lui même
il est amputé d'une jambe des doigts de
la main gauche et il ne peut plus parler
[Musique]
à cette époque tous ceux qui parlent de
corruption autour de l'autoroute se font
agresser
les médias nationaux s'en émeuve les
russes manifeste
mais quand le grand patron de vinci
débarque en russie en 2010 il rend un
hommage appuyé aux autorités russes nous
avons une très bonne coopération avec le
gouvernement et les autorités russes et
nous apprécions leur détermination leur
pragmatisme et leur efficacité
quelques mois après cette déclaration
un nouveau journalistes accusant les
autorités de corruption dans
l'attribution du marché de l'autoroute
est violemment tabassé à moscou toujours
par des inconnus l'image de cette caméra
de surveillance fera le tour du monde
mikhaïl beketov le premier journaliste
qui avait critiqué l'autoroute n'a pas
eu la chance de survivre au printemps
après cinq ans de souffrance il est
décédé à moscou
un activiste nous emmène sur sa tombe
avec les autres opposants il s'est
cotisé pour offrir à beketov ce petit
monument funéraire
oui il est devenu aéro pour les actifs
c'était avant tout un journaliste qui
voulait toujours dire la vérité et il
avait expliqué dès le début donc comment
étrangement le gouvernement avait choisi
le projet le plus cher un énorme contrat
entre l'état et une société étrangère
des opposants tabassés ou tués pour les
russes
aucun doute ce projet d'autoroute est un
moyen pour des proches de vladimir
poutine de s'enrichir en proche de
mikhaïl beketov iec gagna tchirikova a
tenté d'en savoir plus en 2010 elle
contacte cee banque watch une ong
tchèque spécialisée dans la lutte anti
corruption
après plusieurs mois d'enquêté les ong
retrace le financement de l'autoroute
entre vinci et ses partenaires russes
à l'arrivée ce schéma en apparence
incompréhensibles ou l'argent passe par
des comptes à chypre aux îles vierges
britanniques mais aussi au liban et aux
bahamas
de quoi embrouiller les meilleurs
enquêteurs à un détail près en cherchant
bien l'omg découvre parmi les
bénéficiaires du marché de l'autoroute
un certain arkadi rotenberg
arkadi rotenberg un ami d'enfance de
vladimir poutine
les deux hommes partagent la passion du
judo coïncidence troublante quand
poutine devient président son ami
rotenberg devient milliardaire dans le
btp depuis rotenberg fuit la presse
seule cette petite vidéo révèle la
familiarité que le maître du kremlin
entretien avec lui on voit les liens là
c'est la compagnie de rotenberg à 100% à
chypre c'est incroyable d'avoir montré
qu'ils profitent de l'autoroute mais
c'est parce que ces gens-là nous
prennent pour des abrutis
jamais il ne se serait douté que des
petites gens comme nous irait enquêté
sur eux jusqu'à chypre pour retrouver
des documents monaco ça montre bien
qu'ils se croient intouchables
si nos dirigeants ont lancé ce projet
d'autoroute c'est bien pour prendre des
commissions
[Musique]
pour evgenia l'autoroute
moscou-saint-pétersbourg est d'abord une
pompe à fric en russie ces dépôts de
plaintes sont restées lettre morte
mais à 3000 km de moscou le dossier
pourrait peut-être avancer à paris en
juillet 2013
la justice française a été saisie par
sherpa une association de lutte contre
la corruption
merci bonjour william bourdon son
fondateur a porté plainte contre la
filiale russe de vinci pour corruption
d'agent public
il ya eu des fraudes organisées
éventuellement au plus haut niveau et
que donc la cale pour l'instant de
déposer que contre la société vinci de
droit russe il appartiendra aux
enquêteurs de déterminer si le groupe
français et ses différentes structures
ont été bénéficiaires malgré eux de
cette fraude ont été partie prenante de
cette fraude
vinci à tallinn ici le schéma ou at elle
été contrainte de faire du business à la
mode russe
contrainte par le kremlin
dans sa plainte cher pas si de vladimir
poutine lui même comme un des
bénéficiaires potentiels du chantier de
l'autoroute ce qui nous apparaît tout
citer ce dont s'est pas projeté tel ou
tel mot pâture mais c'est sa très grande
proximité avec artie rotenberg a des
traces du fait que ces deux hommes ont
loué aurait pu nouer des partenariats
certain nombre d'autres affaires depuis
des années est-ce que ce milliardaire
porte pour poutine c'est une question
gigantesque très compliqué parce que
tous les acteurs de la cité si des rues
et d'autres savent que s'agissant des
détournements de fonds réussie que
vladimir poutine est sans doute un des
hommes les plus prudents les plus
sophistiqués dans la façon de faire des
coups type fait taire tous ceux qui ont
eu l'audace la naïveté l'appui dance 2 2
de le juger petite victoire pour les
activistes russe en octobre 2013
le parquet de paris a décidé d'ouvrir
une enquête préliminaire
contacté à propos de cette plante de
sherpas pour corruption
le groupe vinci actuellement dirigé par
xavier huillard a décliné toute
interview
sachez que nous réfutons en totalité ses
allégations avec la plus grande fermeté
et que nous ne souhaitons pas rentrer
dans des discussions d'ordre politique
le groupe vinci est dotée d'une charte
éthique et comportements qui encadrent
toutes nos actions
nous avons aussi envoyé un fax au
kremlin réponse des communicants de
poutine un démenti catégorique la
supposition selon laquelle vladimir
poutine aurait pu apporter du soutien à
une quelconque structure commerciale
pour qu'elle obtienne des marchés de
construction ne correspond à aucune
réalité
la plainte déposée en france fera t-elle
bouger la justice russe
à moscou en tout cas outin continue de
jouer les présidents modeste dans sa
déclaration de patrimoine rendu public
avant la présidentielle de 2012
il ne déclare que 140 mille euros de
revenus annuels soit 12000 euros par
mois son salaire officiel son patrimoine
se limiteraient dans un modeste
appartement de 77 mètres carrés un
garage de 18 mètres carrés et trois
voitures des lada message aux électeurs
poutine n'est pas riche pourtant il a
une passion coûteuse qu'il n'arrive pas
à dissimuler les montres de luxe sur
internet
le parti d'opposition solidarnost se
moque de ce point faible parmi ces
montres une patek philippe à 18 milles
dollars
belga une breguet à 15000 dollars
on a même vu à son poignet une patek
philippe en or blanc à 60 mille dollars
le plus hallucinant c'est que le tsar
poutine en distribue régulièrement à ces
sujets comme si c'était de la verroterie
ici un ouvrier une blancpain à 7000
euros là à un berger le même modèle est
encore là même sacrifié pour fêter la
première pierre d'un chantier à nouveau
sept mille euros
il y aurait même une montre que vladimir
poutine ne porterais qu'en privé un
modèle d'exception à 400000 euros
dans ces vidéos le parti d'opposition
solidarnost estime la collection de
montres de vladimir poutine à 500000
euros
rendu public en juin 2012 cette
estimation n'a pas été démentie en
russie se moquer de la corruption
supposée du président est devenu un
sport national
lors de la dernière présidentielle des
opposants ont posté sur youtube des
dizaines de vidéos satiriques comme
celle ci un trucage montrant vladimir
poutine jugés pour corruption
beaucoup les chefs d'accusation son
voile à grande échelle et à vue de
pouvoir décliner votre identité
vladimir poutine nationalité citoyens
russes à la même époque
l'opposition utiliser le même angle
d'attaqué dans ses meetings
honte à poutine le voleur doit aller en
prison
et ce n'est pas nous qui l'enverront là
bas c'est la vérité la loi et la justice
boutineau prison poutine en prison oh
mais il en faudrait plus pour faire
chuter le favori des sondages
peut-être parce que tous les moyens sont
bons pour dominer ses rivaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on dit
mars 2012 vladimir poutine est
effectivement réélu président de la
fédération de russie avec 63,6 % des
voix il saura donc aux premières loges
pour profiter de son grand projet les
jeux olympiques de sotchi au guatemala
il ya sept ans pour le vote final du cio
sur les jo d'hiver 2014
il avait été le premier lobbyiste russe
allant jusqu à s'exprimer en français la
langue olympique et sur les présidents
mamadou ceo
mesdames et messieurs s'étonner s'il
vous plaît le rêve olympique des
millions de russes qui atteindront leur
décision avec l'espoir
je le remercie joie des officiels
annoncent de la victoire pour la liesse
populaire
cet autre chose
[Musique]
ce soir d'octobre 2013 la flamme
olympique traverse moscou mais il n'y a
pas de spectateurs seulement des
policiers et une mascarade publicitaires
c'est un bol cruel la flamme va même
s'éteindre
[Musique]
lorsque nous arrivons à sotchi en
octobre 2013
la signalisation olympique est déjà en
place comme si les sites étaient prêts
nous avons rendez vous avec natalia
kalinowski ya vous imaginez ça devait
être fournie pour le 1er janvier 2013
assistante parlementaire elle est l'une
des rares élues locales a osé dénoncer
publiquement un pillage en règle de
l'argent public
bah c'est le grand stade de 40000 places
au match aller il a déjà coûté 580
millions d'euros
et il n'est même pas fini 580 millions
trois fois plus que les 187 millions du
devis et là bas plus loin c'est quoi ces
méfaits ça c'est l'iceberg pour le
patinage artistique c'est environ 210
millions d'euros 210 millions trois fois
les 75 millions annoncés au départ une
gabegie calculé par l'opposition à
partir de chiffres officiels
comment expliquer ces surcoûts où va
l'argent à sotchi
un petit chef d'entreprise travaillant
pour les jo nous interpeller dans la rue
nous lui proposons un rendez vous
discret le soir même
nicolas l'homme veut rester anonyme
c'est un sous traitant qui loue sa
flotte de camions de chantier il décrit
un système de pots de vin bien organisée
d'abord avec la police le marché sait
que pour être tranquille pour travailler
tu donnes environ 300 euros par camion
loué chaque semaine à la police
commission également pour les chefs de
chantier
quand je dis à mon client quand est ce
que tu me payes mais trois cent mille
euros de factures il me répond donne moi
d'abord les 25000 euros de commission
que je t'ai demandé et après je te
paierai ils ont tellement peur de ne pas
toucher leurs pots de vin qu'il faut
toujours le leur donnez à l'avance mais
cette corruption du quotidien n'est
qu'une mise en bouche à sotchi
c'est à nouveau une histoire de route
qui ferait s'envoler la facture des giro
dans des proportions délirantes
natalia nous emmène sur le chantier de
la nationale qui reliera sotchi au site
de ski alpin à 50 km de là une voix
olympiques dont le coût final s'annonce
pharaonique
combien coûte un kilomètre de route ici
ici en moyenne le kilomètre coûté en
149 millions d'euros en france même
l'autoroute des titans en maurienne n'a
pas dépassé 21 millions d'euros km 6
fois moins cher
à sotchi la nouvelle national coûtera
plus de 7 milliards d'euros pour 48 km
un record mondial
comment ça s'explique c'est inexplicable
il n'y a aucun prix comparable dans le
monde pour natalia vladimir poutine a sa
part de responsabilité il l'a dit
lui-même il faut que tout soit prêt à
temps pour les jeux olympiques à
n'importe quel prix parmi les
entrepreneurs présents à sotchi
un certain arkadi rotenberg le
milliardaire judokas ami d'enfance de la
lumière poutine sur les trois dernières
années d'après les bilans de ces
entreprises
arkadi rotenberg or et engrangé 4
milliards d'euros de commandes pour les
jo
aujourd'hui de source officielle russe
la facture de sotchi dépasse déjà les 37
milliards d'euros
c'est plus que les factures des six
derniers jeux olympiques d'hiver
additionnés
[Musique]
le gâteau est énorme comme si ce qui
distribuait les parts dans l'ombre avait
perdu tout sens de la mesure
pour comprendre rendez vous avec un
entrepreneur russe du bâtiment réfugié à
londres
pour valérie morozov si la facture de
sotchi dérape à ce point c'est en partie
à cause de l'administration poutine
en 2007 il décrochait à sotchi un
contrat 40 millions d'euros pour rénover
ce palais construit sous staline
c'est l'un des plus beaux bâtiments que
j'ai jamais vu c'est pour loger les
membres du cio
mais ce contrat avec un prix valérie
morozov le découvre quand il se rend à
moscou pour le signer avec un directeur
adjoint de l'administration
présidentielle et le type me dis ok
voilà comment ça se passe pour tous les
contrats qui passe par mois il faut
payer ça il prend une feuille de papier
et les cris de 12% et il dit c'est ce
que tu me redonnera 12% soit près de 5
millions d'euros de pots-de-vin pour
l'administration présidentielle et il
m'a dit si tu ne payes dépasser 12%
alors je ne vais pas signer le papier
qui te permettra d'avoir vu
définitivement ce marché nos deux mèches
to your dragon le plus incroyable c'est
que le gars m'a dit ouvertement
cet argent n'est pas seulement pour moi
je vais en randonnée vers ou plus haut
les responsables de l'administration
présidentielle savent que de l'argent
est prêt ils ne savent pas seulement ils
se tiennent ils se protègent les uns les
autres c'est le système qui est comme ça
il ne s'arrête que lorsqu'il n'y a plus
d'argent inc
morozov raconte une corruption sans
limite et au plus haut niveau de l'état
en 2010 les autorités britanniques l'ont
jugé suffisamment crédible pour lui
accorder l'asile politique
[Musique]
dans son témoignage il n'y a pas la
preuve que vladimir poutine s'est
enrichi personnellement cette preuve un
autre entrepreneur russe prétend la
détenir et pour cause il aurait lui-même
contribué à enrichir le président russe
de centaines de millions de dollars mais
en dénonçant poutine lui aussi est
devenu un fugitif
rendez-vous à tallinn en estonie
saion voilà chanterai apa je suis prêt
sergueï kolesnikov est devenu un fantôme
de la russie de poutine
et pourtant c'est à visage découvert
qu'il raconte son départ précipité de
russie en septembre 2010 comme en pleine
guerre froide
un jour j'ai pris un petit sac et je me
suis embarqué dans le premier avion pour
la turquie de là bas je suis parti vers
les états unis
parce qu'un vol direct pour les états
unis ça aurait pu éveiller les soupçons
vous savez la menace la plus sérieuse
contre mois sortait tout droit de la
bouche de poutine ils avaient dit les
traîtres ne vivent jamais très longtemps
des menaces de mort quasi explicite il
faut dire que selon sergueï kolesnikov
la dîmière poutine forêt lui-même du
business une affirmation tabou en russie
le président russe aurait était
l'actionnaire cachée d'une entreprise de
matériel médical petro med une
entreprise dans sergueï kolesnikov
détenait lui aussi départ dès l'entrée
de vladimir poutine au capital et romane
aurait reçu beaucoup de commandes
publiques
mais avec un tel partenaire certains
actionnaires aurait pris peur au point
de s'espionner les uns les autres
pouvez vous nous montrez ici
je peux vous faire entendre des
enregistrements ici sur ces
enregistrements
une conversation entre sergueï
kolesnikov et d'autres associés quelques
mois seulement avant sa fuite
l'atmosphère est tendue on y parle de
millions de dollars et surtout d'un gros
bénéfices à partager avec un grand
absent un certain michael ivanovic
l'argent qu'il ya là il est à nouveau à
michail ivanovic a mitraillé ivanovic il
y à 439 millions $ jour j c'est son
argent c'est la part qui lui revenait à
cet instant c'est moi qui parle je parle
de l'argent de michail ivanovic michail
ivanovic c'est-à-dire vladimir poutine
oui c'est son surnom
oui c'est son nom de code imer un nom de
code comme s'il y avait quelque chose à
cacher c'est à dire que michail ivanovic
donc poutine n'est pas seulement le
président de la russie mais aussi un
businessman
officiellement il ne pouvait pas assumer
bien sûr les businessmans c'était notre
mais le bénéficiaire c'était bien
michail ivanovic ça
michail ivanovic alias vladimir poutine
avec les seuls dividendes de petro med
il aurait empoché 439 millions de
dollars plus tard dans la soirée
sergueï kolesnikov nous fait une
nouvelle révélation la richesse de la
demir poutine serait visible quelque
part dans le sud de la russie depuis
début 2009
le président s'y ferait construire un
petit versailles à guelendjik au bord de
la mer noire
un jour mais à ivanovic le surnom de
vladimir poutine entre nous quand on
parlait de business donc michail
ivanovic nous ordonne d'arrêter les
autres projets il dit que ça ne
l'intéresse plus ils voulaient que nous
consacrions toute notre énergie et tout
son argent à lui construire un palais à
guelendjik à palets sur google earth
il y est bien traces du site dont parle
sergueï kolesnikov
c'est dans le sud de la russie au bord
de la mer noire
un gigantesque complexe apparaît google
appelle carrément le palais de poutine
il y a même des photos prises par des
ouvriers au moment des travaux
une entrée monumentale un palais immense
et un parc au cordeau et voici à quoi
ressemblerait l'intérieur pour tenter de
savoir si ce palais appartient bien à
vladimir poutine
nous nous en voulons pour la mer noire à
guelendjik nous contactons un activiste
de l'opposition pour s'être intéressée
d'un peu trop près au mystérieux pas les
trois de ses amis ont été jetés en
prison
c'est à gueye accepte tout de même de
nous guider
la propriété est très protégée sur des
kilomètres un premier mur d'enceinte et
ce poste de contrôle en le ballet reste
invisible
loin derrière ces collines par la
falaise
il est possible de s'approcher mais
c'est risqué
je me suis fait arrêter une fois ici par
des gardiens ont fouillé ils ont détruit
mes photos et ils m'ont emmené à la
police ici on a des hommes ou des gardes
frontière les services spéciaux de la
présidence et des hommes du fsb je les
ai vus plusieurs fois
la sécurité est draconienne tout cela
confirme que c'est bien le palais
poutine la clôture s'avance dans l'eau
sur plusieurs dizaines de mètres pour la
contourner par la mer
nous louons un bateau nous filmé en
caméra discrète
sergei nous prévient laventure pourrait
s'arrêter dès la sortie du port
maintenant va dépendre des garde côtes
qui surveillent la zone
nous prenant pour des touristes les
gardes-côtes nous laisse passer
et puis nous remontons la rive à toute
vitesse pendant une vingtaine de minutes
c'est là la maison de poutine le fameux
pas d'ennemis en haut des falaises
nous apercevons ce gigantesque complexe
avec ses antennes
comme si le site servait aussi de centre
que le commandement
[Musique]
aura des vagues un bon ton en
construction et l'entrée d'un tunnel un
univers façon james bond
[Musique]
au dessus des logements peut-être pour
le personnel
[Musique]
il est temps de faire demi tour
question
combien a coûté la construction de ce
petit versailles à tallinn sergueï
kolesnikov l'ancien associé de poutine a
son idée quinze mille mètres carrés du
marbre des dorures
il a fait les comptes j'estime la valeur
du palais aujourd'hui à près d'un
milliard de dollars une somme
faramineuse mais d'après un politologue
russe spécialiste de la corruption
l'investissement est tout à fait dans
les cordes du du multimilliardaire que
serait aujourd'hui vladimir poutine les
informations sont basées sur des
déclarations de proches de poutine
aujourd'hui et oui ni aucun des actifs
nets au nom de poutine sont aux noms de
ses proches ses actifs dont sa propriété
indirecte
il ya surtout des actions de gazprom de
sourgout ni gaz et de gore d'après moi
ça représente 40 milliards de dollars
plus le cache que génèrent ces actions
c'est pour ça que j'estime que poutine
est l'homme le plus riche d'europe
la question c'est juste ton comment
peut-il utiliser cet argent sachant
qu'il n'a pas de droit direct de sueur
et que bien sûr s'il se rend devant un
notaire en europe ou ailleurs on dire
c'est moi le bénéficiaire final mois le
président russe
là ce n'est pas possible bladimir
poutine at-il prisonnier de ce système
si l'opposition prenait le pouvoir il
devrait probablement rendre des comptes
pour garder la main sur ce qui serait la
plus grande fortune d'europe
le tsar n'aurait d'autre choix que de
rester au kremlin du coup d'après son
ancien sherpa
c'est toute la russie qui serait devenu
otage du système poutine avec le système
qu'il a mis en place cyber donc tout
line s'est engagé lui même dans une voie
sans issue
plus transmettre la présidence à qui tu
reçois poste et outils kaboul cher en
2006 ou 2007 il a pensé sérieusement à
repartir dans le privé un peu chaud
qu'au bout de chou animaux j mais quand
il a étudié la question
il s'est rendu compte que s'il quittait
le pouvoir pour cette personne ne
pourrait garantir sa sécurité
personnelle ont boudé de maaf a dit ça
il restera donc au plus haut poste
jusqu'à la fin
que ce soit une fin naturelle des chupa
ministre jusqu'où vladimir poutine
ira-t-il pour conserver son pouvoir
et jusqu'à quand pour protéger le
système
il a déjà modifié la constitution
écraser l'opposition en 2018 et même au
delà
tout est en place pour que se répètent à
l'infini cette même cérémonie la prise
de la russie par la dîmière poutine
[Musique]
il
et vous